for all that we've already seen about
the upcoming game hitman absolution
there's been one key piece of the puzzle
missing we have not actually seen agent
47 carry out a hit on an unsuspecting
target
all that changes with this year's e3
demo in which you are tasked with
assassinating the king of chinatown now
there's many ways you can do this you
can shoot him with a sniper rifle from a
rooftop you can blow up his car you can
even poison his food we spoke with the
game's art director to find out more
what makes a hitman absolution different
from the previous installments in the
series is the fact that we really wanted
to balance the in-depth mechanics of the
previous series with a more accessible
view to get more players in the
franchise shooting mechanics in
absolution have been balanced much more
and now they do offer a compelling
experience if the player is so inclined
to take the level in this way or if he's
actually forced to resort to violence to
succeed in his uh
in his mission all these features that
make the game more complex they also
have to be accessible to the player and
that has been one of the main focuses
for the team to make to communicate
clearly enough so that most players can
have access to them and enjoy them
there are different
type of levels in hitman absolution the
target can be killed
both with the weapons but also just by
creating maybe an accident in the
environment and this
is something we try to put in in every
single target level that we have in the
game that they can be sold in many
different ways and it's just not
shooting the target that is the the most
viable solution you can also try to be
much more subtle about it it's very easy
to see what would make a bad
assassination i mean collateral damage
in the form of
civilians they're just not very elegant
and then we'll of course have a high
impact on your score
this this course is the
made to support also our rating system
as
it showed up in the left corner of the
screen and it's a two-fold system where
you start out a level with a title that
can be affected according to what you do
this is also where the coveted rating of
signed assassin comes to play if you
actually manage to fulfill all the
requirements for it you will get that
and you'll also get a better score
this score is also tracked on
leaderboards that have uh
that they have
influenced both on on national level but
also on global level so you can compete
with your friends on on a worldwide
level